let's go from Texas to Arizona one way
to avoid cases is not to do any tests
one way to avoid opinions that you
shouldn't reopen your state yet is to
fire the people telling you not to
reopen the state and that is what
Arizona Republican Governor Doug Ducey
did on Monday Ducey said he is
accelerating the reopening of Arizona
that seemed questionable based on the
case numbers which if you look have a
very definitive upward curve spiking to
nearly a new high yesterday matched only
by the numbers on April 30th so the
cases are spiking deaths usually follow
closely behind and Ducey says let's open
up well income the public health
officials who say hey you know look at
the numbers we can't really reopen right
now Ducey doesn't like it so he fires
them Steve Bailey the bureau chief for
Public Health Statistics at the Arizona
Department of Health Services says quote
we've been asked by Department
leadership to pause all current work on
projections and modeling yeah pause it
until the pandemic is gone and then
start modeling again how great the
numbers are these are the people we
should be listening to now the timing is
suspect the timing to me has Trump's
fingerprints all over it
and it seems to have Trump's pressure
all over it because remember that trump
was in Arizona on Tuesday and the day
before Trump shows up Ducey says we're
gonna reverse course from what I said
last week a week ago the governor in
Arizona seemed to be taking this
seriously extended to stay homeowner or
stay at home order until May 15 said
stay at home is working said the data
clearly point to not opening up yet but
then this week we learned Trump's going
to Arizona on Tuesday does a bunch of
grandstanding about reopening and the
great governor Ducey who is there and
getting the economy going again and just
hours before Trump went to Arizona the
day before Ducey decides hey you know
what we are going to open more stuff we
don't need the public health officials
modeling the impact of reopening anymore
and it has Trump's fingerprints all over
it speculative but it's what we know
Trump does Arizona not the only state
that is starting to do strange things we
already talked about Texas five minutes
ago we have reports that Florida or
Florida as some say is hiding
coronavirus deaths by not reporting the
cause of death
people are dying the reporting that a
death took place there not including the
cause of death in the reports to the
media and publicly we have reports that
Ohio is changing how it reports numbers
from a five-day to a 21-day timeframe to
make it seem as though the numbers are
going down what I believe is going on
here and I believe Donald Trump's past
behavior and statements justify at least
exploring this is that the efforts are
becoming more about let's not talk about
the deaths let's not talk about anything
that's going on medically let's just
insist we're past the peak and let's
talk about reopening let's talk about
CEOs and States and all of this other
states opening businesses and all of
that and as usual the very thing the
Trump administration is accusing others
of doing is what it seems like they
themselves are doing some use the term
projection to describe this we're
hearing more and more that the Trump
administration is questioning whether
the death numbers are accurate or
whether they are higher than the real
numbers meanwhile what we're learning
about are the strategies being employed
by the Trump administration and by
States to make it a case that the death
numbers are actually lower than what
they really are while insisting that the
testing is greater than what it actually
is Trump can keep repeating 2.2 million
deaths all he wants but he for week said
60,000 60,000 60,000 we're now at 75,000
yesterday 2500 people died the day
before roughly 2500 people died at this
rate we will be at a hundred thousand
cases in ten days and it's going to
continue going and it's a fiasco while
Spain Italy France many other countries
have it under control
don't take my word for it
look at the data coming out of Italy
Spain and France so what do you do if
you're the trump administration when
you've lost control of the situation you
just lie you say the death toll is lower
than what we were told and I'm doing a
great job and testing is great and we're
opening up the country it's a disaster
and people will continue to die